I encourage women to stand up for what
they want and that sounds nice but do
you have it yeah but and that's you
might not have it yeah
you're always going to be so I do
believe that if you have a mindset of
you're going to get something you can
get it yeah can you maintain that it's
got to be realistic which is what you
said in the beginning like people are so
delusional like yeah because yeah but
realistic I feel like it all depends on
how you view life like you said you're
spiritual you view life in a certain way
you like to live a certain way no no
everyone it's dependent outcomes so what
what do you get yes what do you mean so
so okay if you want a traditional
outcome like I'd first ask are you a
traditional woman and and what outcome
will you get what outcome have you
gotten in the past if you've never
gotten that outcome in the past why
would you get it in the future because
raising your standards no because I feel
like where you are now doesn't it
doesn't mean this is where you're always
going to be yeah I realize I know that
your mindset matters so whatever you say
if I say I'm gonna do something I'm
gonna get it done I don't care what okay
I'm gonna do something right but this is
okay so if I'm applying for a CEO job
and they say okay what CEOs have you
worked for before but did you know they
say you know I've worked minimum wage at
McDonald's but I really want the seeds
we didn't talk about that we want it but
it doesn't mean you're going to get it
but there's there's been uh probably
situations where that's happened by
chance and by going right and people win
the lottery and it happens but they're
not going to go and give general advice
and say oh that's going to happen for
most people but but the perfect example
is Tyler Perry it's not going to happen
but you just gotta want it that's what I
believe I don't believe that that
um or totally agree with what you're
saying but I do believe that once you
have the mindset and you desire
something I said I'm not in the 20
doesn't mean that I'm not going to be
one day maybe I want to be and maybe I
will be that's all my mindset and what I
choose to be on the 20 with a kid who
says that it's man why can't I mean I'm
sorry it's not no sorry
I'm a mom could I finish talking and
nobody can limit me no one can limit me
there's there's no limitation so if I
want to be in that 20 and I believe I'm
going to be a 20 with my six-year-old I
am going to be in it that's because
that's my mind that's how I feel yeah
the top 20 of men what they want but
that's fine and I'm telling you I've
interviewed these men yeah but they
don't they don't that's fine but mothers
typically but typically they don't want
but I'm sure there's a small percentage
that will and you'll find that
experiences Sierras exist but they look
like Sierra and they have Sierra
outcomes yeah but the thing is
exceptions they're not the rules that's
fine I know I'm not Sierra I'm Janae
Simone so whatever Janae Simone wants is
she's gonna put her mind to it she's
going to get it so you might not the
percent or the what statistics may go
against me but I know who I am and I
know what I want so yes I have a
six-year-old and yes I was a teenage mum
but that doesn't Define me you're not
that's who I am I who I was when I was
18. I'm saying it defines you but it
influences your outcomes it influences
my outcomes but it doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't 100 factual that that's going to
be my outcome statistics can say
whatever but from what I believe and
where I come from and what I know and
what I've seen what I want I will get if
I want to be a housewife I'll be a
housewife if I don't want to be do you
think it's wise to tell single mothers
that they're going to typically be in
the top 20 I think it's wise to tell
single mothers sorry sorry do you think
that's honest no to be honest with you I
don't think that is on it it's not about
honest it's about letting people know if
you believe something and you're going
to work towards it it's very important
it's not unrealistic it's unrealistic in
terms of statistics and I understand you
want to be an exception to the rule it's
unrealistic to leave it's not a single
more exceptional it's not about it it's
not about trying to be like no you're
you're unique in your circumstance and
you believe you can no it's not saying
that it's just who I am it's not I don't
want to yeah but you're not everybody
now speaking from not statistical like
it's very honesty wow so what I must say
to someone you're going to be statistic
I get a point of view but it's just to
tell at large single mothers they've got
a chance I'm not gonna tell I'm not
telling them that was the question
though so I think that's unrealistic so
do you think I don't think it's
unrealistic I don't think it's
unrealistic I don't think so I'm not
gonna well actually
because I'm not going to look at someone
I don't care what situation you're in
now you can be homeless poor broke I'm
not gonna look at you and tell you your
statistic I said you're going to still
be here I agree I agree I agree I agree
it doesn't it I didn't say you no no I
didn't say it I didn't say anything I'm
saying I'm not saying that every single
mother is going to die alone but I'm
saying if they expect to to get with the
top 20 of men [__] they might yeah
because they're holding out for men that
typically you don't want them top top 20
percent I don't even think I deserve the
top 20 of them I like it that's it's
about yeah
you're an eight out of ten or higher
yeah I mean are they like you said
before like you said before men don't
really you're saying they don't look at
the parents eight out of ten so that
wouldn't really matter in hindsight
you're saying that they don't look at
appearance oh no they start it starts
with looks okay
lip fillers oh okay well my point of
view is that I would never look at
somebody and say because of where you
are today or what you have today or what
you what you've got you're not going to
be able to get I would I would say
because of choices that you've made it
is unlikely that you will be in that
position that's your opinion it's not
it's not an opinion it's looking at
outcome it's looking at outcomes but but
then there's many outcomes that I can
change I can change I'm not going to be
the same single mother in five years but
yeah I don't believe that and I'm not
gonna but you can't change what men
value and yeah but I can find someone
that doesn't agree with that and and
typically that's not going to be the top
20. typically that's typically
and miracles happen but it's not the
rule it's not the rule but who says I
think it's dishonest to say that it's
likely that that single mothers are
gonna get the top 20. it's not dishonest
because it's been happy it's happened it
happens I'm not gonna it's not dishonest
I'm letting people know that what you
desire is achievable
it's achievable I'm not going to sit and
tell someone because statistics says
that you're not going to find someone in
20 you're not but no so here's why like
women like prefer to be lied to because
that's a lie it's not a lie
let me let me okay okay blessing
blessing
yeah do men typically want single
mothers no no see that's what but that's
used that's a blessing I'm
back
for example I've been do you know as
well it also depends on what type of
single mother you are no I don't know
can I finish sorry um so I'm a single
mother yes I am I would have my
daughter's died for seven years that was
it one partner before him then my
daughter's dad that's it I'm very what's
the word if I explain it it does it's
not hard for me to find someone but I'm
selective and I which I am allowed to be
but that's because I want to get married
I do not rule out someone like me
meeting someone that's gonna value them
because they don't have a child I didn't
say you wouldn't find it no no but I'm
just saying I said the top 20 of men is
probably unrealistic however and I and
it doesn't and it doesn't all men feel
this way yep that's okay about any kid
any kid because biologically they don't
have a biological incentive to do so
okay but just to let you I just know
that's impossible can you can you like
can you say back what I said what did
you say sorry men don't have a
biological imperative to raise other
people's kids
wait wait wait wait their their goal is
to pass on their genes yeah but I've
seen it happens okay okay their their
goal is to pass on their genes yeah but
that so that's specifically right wait
wait wait wait okay their their goal is
to pass on their genes and so marrying a
single mother they're putting their
resources their time and their energy
into a kid that's not theirs okay and
legally they have no rights to okay so
they could raise a kid for 10 years you
could change your mind tomorrow and say
you know what I'm not feeling this
anymore and take the kid they reached
for 10 years so but I have to wait it
and miracles happen but it's not the
rule yeah
wait wait okay where women women it's
not the same because if a guy has a kid
that's like signals other women want him
and so that's a sign of pre-selection so
back in the back in the jungle or
whatever if I saw a guy with a kid that
said hey she picked him and he could
take care of that kid so I should pick
him too so we just don't view it the
same way yeah but I still I I don't
agree I know that some there is men out
there that will take me on and marry me
with my one child and there's men out
there that will take whatever can I
finish there's men out there there's men
out there that will take on a woman with
six children and marry them wait there's
always going to be somebody but always
always but no the type of man that's not
typically the top 20 of men yeah but
that's typically you're talking about
realistically if I've set myself
something I know I'm gonna get it so you
might say I'm delusional No One's Gonna
want one one I don't know
but I'm not saying that I'm just saying
other people might think that oh you're
delusional
no but I'm just I'm just trying to say
other people may see that or who wants
because I've heard it many times who
wants somebody with a child nobody wants
that but in reality they do it doesn't
happen it doesn't maybe that's what you
think I agree they do because it's cool
I believe you could actually like sit
men down and I'd say no
I don't agree I've seen it and now
that's delusional because you're in
denial of the truth because that's the
truth so you believe that I believe you
can find a man in the top 20 and you'd
be an exceptionally rare case what have
you sat 10 men down here majority if not
all of them would say they don't want to
raise someone else's child okay maybe
that's true but from my own experiences
I don't I know people that have raised
other people's children and I don't
believe they love them in the same way
I'm a stepchild however this opposite
way my dad married so okay so I've seen
it but it's from a woman's point of view
and I've also seen people take on other
people's children and they're a man it
does happen but is is are you raised by
a man in the top 20 is what she's saying
is like you're not getting the top 20
you're going to be but I don't accept
any rare case well I'm not saying it's
not possible I'm not doubting like what
you're saying you believe in yourself
you believe you can get it you can get
it but it's you're going to be in a rare
case yeah as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick-Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible